this video is sponsored by
curiositystream
in a distant future on a distant planet
a group of people are contained inside a
large
warehouse-sized dome building inside
there is nothing covering the curved
wall however
is a set of screens on which a series of
digital images and videos are projected
at all times
the individuals inside are prisoners
more precisely they are the children of
prisoners
many years ago after they had ventured
out too far into the unknown regions of
the cosmos
and entangled themselves with another
species far exceeding their intellectual
weight class
their parents had been captured and
after being determined
as a quote potentially infective
malignant risk
they were imprisoned in complete
isolation quarantined from ever making
contact with the outside world
again as part of the protocol for such a
process
the infants on board were separated from
their parents
onto a different planet now having been
inside this building essentially since
birth for reasons and a backstory they
would not even understand
these infants now turned adults know
only the images and videos selected and
projected by their captors onto the
screens
to them the building structure contains
everything there is
and the digital renderings are the true
forms of things
they are reality
the visuals are played to the prisoners
for ethical reasons
based on strict statutes and guidelines
regarding interactions
and imprisonment of intergalactic
species the captors are required by
their own law
to one not kill any well-intending lower
conscious beings
and two provide all isolated infantile
prisoners
of any species and any being forms of
perceptual simulation
the prisoners are also fed and hydrated
through an automated misting delivery
mechanism
that periodically and densely fills the
structure with various nutrient and
water molecules
which are then absorbed by the
prisoner's skin the floor is also made
of a particular technology
that absorbs and cleans all waste
it has been many many years and the
prisoners remain
contained inside the building structure
at some point
some many years ago they began
considering and asking questions about
what they saw on the screen wall
trying to master their knowledge of the
world around them creating language and
naming the images and scenes
taking great pride in their individual
efforts and abilities to analyze
and understand it some of the prisoners
have found themselves especially well
versed at intellectualizing
and naming the digital renderings some
even producing theories and concepts to
explain the nature of it all
over time some of these theories have
since turned into dogmas
that the rest of the prisoners believed
to be fixed and unquestionably true
one individual in particular named cato
is one of the more curious and
intelligent prisoners
he is responsible for a huge portion of
the language the prisoners have created
and he has been heavily involved in
developing theories and knowledge that
the prisoners now hold to be true
while on one of his regular walks around
the internal perimeter
as he often does he looks close up at
the screen wall
moving around and laying on the ground
to get a different angle putting his
nose nearly right up on the screen's
surface
examining and questioning it while doing
this
on this particular day he notices
something unusual he's never seen before
a slight crack on the ground like all
things in existence
no matter how well built the building
structure is beginning to decay
and cato observes the very ground of
reality crack beneath him
having never seen anything like it
before kato is completely dumbfounded
initially his mind plays tricks on him
and prevents him from really perceiving
its jagged dimensional nature
and he only processes a 2d version of it
after looking more closely at it however
he touches it and feels the texture of
the raised pieces against the divots
eventually he pushes on it it cracks
further
he pushes on it again this time harder
it cracks even further
soon cato finds himself with a small
hole in front of him
he stares into it after much internal
debate
compelled by his high level of curiosity
and desire for knowledge
he enters and begins to dig and dig and
dig
after great exertion fear and discomfort
he emerges into the world beyond the
structure
immediately he becomes so disoriented
his mind goes into a shock-like state
as time passes though his shock slowly
turns into disbelief
and then into revelation he sees a world
of three-dimensionality made of layers
and elevation and cracks and holes and
all the rest
he sees objects with a physical
touchable movable nature
he sees the sun and feels its warmth he
sees a tree and climbs upon it
he sees animals and life forms that move
and interact with him as he encounters
them
he sees water and submerges into it
feeling its wetness
he sees things that he had previously
only known on the screen wall
he quite suddenly realizes everything he
has known since birth
the two-dimensional single-display
rendering of a unified reality
everything he had ever talked about and
called true
was now revealing itself to merely be a
surface representation
the source the truth cato realizes
is out here after exploring for a little
while
cato returns to the building structure
compelled to share what he has
discovered
he climbs back down into the hole and
re-enters the building
he approaches the group collected in the
center and informs them of what he has
experienced
and seen we are living a lie he says
there's a whole world beyond this world
the real world
there are different things you can touch
them pick them up
move them there are different cato
doesn't know the words to describe the
new
external textures so he tries making
hand signals to represent
slimy and wet and spiky and so forth
some things you can even go inside he
continues
i floated in something climb something
else there's a whole surface above us
out there with things floating around
one made me feel different it hurt to
look at but it was so beautiful
cato doesn't know the word or concept
for warm so he makes a body motion that
looks like he's melting
i swear to you all i have seen the truth
i've seen the source
and nature of things as they really are
all the other prisoners believe cato has
gone mad
with no experience of the world beyond
the building structure
comprehending beyond it without the
framework or terms
is like trying to scientifically explain
color to someone who's never seen any
to understand a complete truth one must
not merely possess the knowledge of it
but also the experience of it quickly
another intellectually considerate
prisoner named lex grabs kato and pulls
him to the side
what's wrong with you lex says you're
freaking me out right now
and you're freaking everyone else out
too it's true i can show you
cato replies he escapes lex's grip and
returns to the group
i can show you all it's right over here
he points to the hole in the distance of
the building
you've gone insane wherever you went
whatever's going on with you
we don't want anything to do with it one
prisoner yells out
cato gestures and moves towards the hole
anyway most of the prisoners ignore him
some however follow him once at the
whole
like cato did they struggle to
comprehend what they are seeing
their eyes and minds play tricks on them
rationalizing the whole as
anything other than a whole however as
they reach their hand out and experience
the depth of it
and the feeling of the cracking texture
some begin to take cato more seriously
now having seen it for themselves these
individuals enter the hole with cato
and exit the building structure emerging
into the world beyond
like kato was they are immediately
shocked by the sensory overload
as they adjust though they begin to
process and feel everything
they see the sun and feel its warmth
they move rocks
touch plants they feel texture they see
dimension
you were right another prisoner exclaims
to cato
in awe after a little exploring the
whole group returns to the building
structure to tell the other prisoners
that cata was right that they have seen
the truth
after attempting to explain the other
prisoners who have remained inside
become increasingly concerned and
hostile believing that cato has now
somehow brainwashed the others
simultaneously cato and the others
knowing they know the real truth and
that the others are ignorant to it
feel they must defend it after some
arguing back and forth
a fight breaks out fists swinging legs
kicking
voices screaming the prisoners who
remained inside are not only comfortable
in their ignorance
but are also deeply upset by the attempt
to point it out
part of ignorance after all is the
refusal to admit it
the succumbing to the pain of potential
wrongness with denial
and resistance cato steps in
and stops the whole debacle enough he
says
if you do not want the truth then so be
it i for one
want to live in the truth the world of
things as they really
are i'm leaving for the final time to
live in that world
i have shown those who would like to see
and for anyone who would like to join me
now
you may do so about half of those who
left with him originally
leave with him again the rest stays
[Music]
cato and the group that goes with him go
on to live explore
discuss and redefine reality in the
world beyond the structure
eventually going on to reproduce and
begin an entirely new population of
their species
cato becomes a leader of sorts as they
name new objects
new motions new phenomena they come up
with new terms and theories to fill in
the gaps between their experience of
reality
and their comprehension of it they form
primarily led by cato
new dogmatic belief systems the group
feels an increasingly superior grasp of
knowledge over those who remained inside
the building structure
they call themselves the enlightened
ones the truth knowers
[Music]
back inside the building one of the
prisoners has continued to second guess
her choice to stay
ever since the group divided she
frequently goes over to the hole when no
one is looking
and stares into it the group if they
ever catch her
quickly scolds and stops her today
however
compelled by her growing curiosity she
finally enters the hole
and leaves the building structure once
outside
she goes a slightly different direction
than cato and the others
simultaneously at a remote monitoring
station about one light year away
an alarm goes off a security guard on
shift at the station
monitoring hundreds of thousands of
jails across the galaxy cluster
waves his hand at a holographic screen
another screen appears revealing the
prisoner leaving the building as well as
cato and the rest of the prisoners
outside
the guard taps at a holographic button
to the right of him and waits a moment
hello a voice answers a group from
prison ca 53
have exited layer 1 and they appear to
have settled into layer 2 now
the guard says noted thank you the voice
replies
on the holographic screen in front of
the security guard below text that reads
jail ca 53 a check box next to text that
reads
layer 1 fills in with an x
below it is a list that goes on to read
layer 2
layer 3 layer 4 all the way down to
layer
1000 the captur species are not
concerned
they know that as long as the prisoners
believe they have escaped
they will remain imprisoned
[Music]
this video was sponsored by
curiositystream
containing thousands of documentaries
and non-fiction tv series
covering thought-provoking subjects in
science technology
nature history and much more curiosity
stream is the streaming platform
for those who enjoy taking journeys deep
into the world and mind
through film with award-winning
exclusives and originals
by some of the world's best filmmakers
curiosity stream provides beautifully
produced titles
that utilize entertaining narratives and
formats and feature many familiar faces
like stephen hawking jason silva and
david attenborough
to name a few easily pick from 35
expertly curated collections and find
hours and hours of content
streamable on any device at any time
whether you're on your phone
laptop or smart tv curiosity stream's
growing library will ensure that your
unique curiosities can always be
explored
by visiting curiositystream.comwunder or
clicking the link in the description
and using code wonder during sign up you
can start your subscription today for
just 14.99 for the entire year
which equates to just 125 per month
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
you